this is butta butta in the lowlands of
Lesotho where nurse moet game what lot C
is based besides offering health
services she also trains other nurses
working in various health care
facilities in Lesotho as the clinic
armenta I go to the health centers and
what together with a house antennas or
nursing duties basically and activities
that we have to do in regard to health
care services to the patients it also
involves providing the trainings to the
methods especially the new ones who come
from the training strict awake every day
she has to travel far to get to those
who need medical services most
especially those who can't make it to
the nearest health center or hospital
the roads are in poor shape in this
remote mountainous terrain and the
weather can be unpredictable nurse moet
gays colleague or Latin bosun fitori y
la says their work is essential in all
of this I mean we are fighting the
number one killer disease in Lesotho
today which is the hiv/aids pandemic the
suit is number two in the world with
high prevalence of HIV is a hot spot of
HIV so ensuring that communities are
reached without key I mean also it's a
way to ensure to see that this problem
that we are facing is attacked at the
root of baggage which are the community
itself after a few hours drive they
reach their destination today they've
brought their mobile clinic services to
the people of Rocco to on a village the
medical team gets right to work I've
quickly done the TB screening and
because again in this country of high
prevalence of TP now that's the
importance I mean you bring
comprehensive lk and then you're able to
leverage on that to also address the I
prevalent diseases that we have in the
country nurse matka uses this
opportunity to educate young p
about sensitive health issues such as
sexually transmitted diseases and
hiv/aids she gives them advice on how to
protect themselves and others hey look
we were just talking about circumcision
in our language sister to what we saw in
Ascot it helps prevent the spread of
sexually transmitted diseases the World
Health Organization says male
circumcision can help prevent the spread
of HIV but the procedure should be done
by medical professionals in a properly
equipped setting diseases are there and
they're being transmitted but now access
is another thing you can just see the
terrain yeah they have to cross the
revised go down the mountains and
climbed and you can just imagine after
such a pain of the composition I think
it's going to be difficult for someone
to walk such a distance back home the
mobile clinic team will arrange
transport for the young man who wish to
undergo a safe circumcision procedure in
a hospital while dr. fitori la is seeing
more patients in the primary school of
the village nurse Malaika continues her
health education with those still
awaiting consultation it will be a month
before moet k and her team can come back
again